[Music]
the Tony Awards are tomorrow evening the
biggest night for Broadway musicals
usually get most of the attention but
there is a timely play that's already
won the Pulitzer Prize for drama and it
is up for three awards jamie wax is here
with the story good morning Jamie good
morning Alex yes the Broadway play sweat
perfectly captures and some say
predicted some of the most important and
divisive issues of our times such as
race class and immigration research
humanity and tremendous talent combined
on stage and a powerful take on the
plight of the American working class
can you try Jessie home hello
she's the designated driver sweat takes
place almost exclusively inside a bar
it's the happy hour hangout of union
workers in a Redding Pennsylvania steel
factory how important was the setting of
a bar I think for me the bar is a place
where people unwind and people relax but
I also think that liquor has this
incredible power to get people to tell
the truth Lynn Nottage is the playwright
of sweat which is directed by Kate we'll
rinse key matter when I was writing the
play I really felt like I was holding a
hammer in my hand just because I was so
angry about the fact that there was this
huge swath of America that was not being
seen President Clinton has added to his
reputation as the comeback kid by
resurrecting NAFTA when it was all but
written off sweat alternates between six
years after the North American Free
Trade Agreement became law you could
wake up tomorrow all your jobs are in
Mexico whatever it's this adaptable and
the 2008 aftermath of the world
financial crisis we've been evolved over
time for a financial system and our
economy that was a time of bailouts for
car company this is all about a lot more
than just Detroit it's about saving the
US economy from a catastrophic collapse
and big banks in 2011 the Occupy Wall
Street movement drew thousands of angry
Americans including not
and I spent probably another week or two
going to occupy wallstreet and
eventually felt like it wasn't enough I
needed to understand what was happening
in our country why was our American
narrative shifting so quickly an article
in The New York Times led Nottage 150
miles away to reading and it basically
had said that reading was the poor city
of its size what did you find there that
surprised you
when I began interviewing people we
always ask the question how would you
describe your city and people inevitably
said reading was that they always spoke
of their town impasse tense and that
really sort of saddened and shocked me
you have this generational tension in
which you had one generation that was so
aspirational and achieved for so long
that suddenly finds that they can't pass
that same bounty on to their children or
renze Joy Nottage about a year later
together they interviewed locals and
visited places like Mike's tavern
eventually a narrative and characters
began to emerge like Cynthia and Tracy
best friends on the factory floor played
by Tony nominees Michelle Wilson and
Johanna day do you see echoes from your
own lives your own experiences in the
tensions in this play well for sure I'm
from Detroit um when I was saying that
Detroiters were Canaries in the coal
mine ages ago I mean I remember the gas
crisis and I remember them sending
counselors into the schools because the
children were depressed because their
parents were out of work so I know
intimately what it's like to come from a
company town I want an industry town
what you say when Cynthia receives a
promotion relationships begin to fray it
sucks
and I've actually they wanted a minority
I'm not prejudiced but that's how things
are going these days I got eyes they get
tax breaks or something I mean she says
when her character says they're gonna
ask everyone to take a pay cut to save
jobs 60% yo it's not hard to get upset
about that so very real it's an
insurance and your pension in here you
know I mean it's this is the majority of
the world yes what this play these
people in this play he generations of
loyalty to the same company but this is
America right sweat was originally
commissioned by the Oregon Shakespeare
Festival as the play moved from Oregon
to the Public Theater in New York the
political landscape began to shift and
intersect with the script America has
lost seventy thousand factors hard to
believe do you have any sense that those
issues might be boiling over to the
point that they are now um certainly
when we sat down and began speaking with
people in reading we felt their anger
and their frustration we felt a sense of
alienation we felt all of the things
that were reading about today and the
question that we often get asked could
we have predicted that the country would
turn toward trump it's like no but what
we could predict is that this kind of
frustration would take some form of
revolution in some ways it it was
absolutely shocking and in another way
we had access to the motor for five
years I mean for five years we were
hearing the same stories and the same
kind of anger and engine and not
realizing exactly where that that energy
would go since March the production has
been at New York's famed studio 54
theater but before they made the move to
Broadway we've been having the same
conversation for 20 years the cast put
on a special performance for the people
in reading the reaction was startling
like one woman's story told to Johanna
she was in tears because she said we're
not just a block on the Monopoly board
and we're not the brunt of everybody's
jokes we're a play now she said thanks
for not making fun of us
it's just giving a voice why do you
think these people have been invisible
to much of America for so long there
seems to be a resentment towards working
alright so there's something about the
working-class and just the dignity of
Labor of getting up and taking care of
your family that seems to we have a
disconnect right like the easier your
money comes the more worthy you must be
and that you know you're not a sucker
and these people are not suckers they're
hard workers who are doing everything
they're supposed to do yeah cheap
American and even though sweat one Lynn
Nottage her second Pulitzer Prize
believe it or not it is her Broadway
debut and I'll be looking for her
tomorrow night at the Tony Awards a
really important play Jamie we talked
about these issues in the context of
policy or politics but rarely in the
human context you know it's also an
example of what theater can do when you
sit and watch someone interrupted tell
and show their story it really is a
different kind of experience good luck
to them tomorrow night at the Tony's
Jimmy Wax thanks thank you